with Trump being present in the worst
case scenario fire economy it's wars
wars and more Wars best-case scenario
for the economy already happened and
that was Trump getting elected because
Hillary would have destroyed it that he
will destroy too many social services
that the country currently has that
there'll be no social security people
are going to be able to make their own
money and not live off the system that
less funds given through the states are
going to be needed I could find a great
job after I finished grad school and be
able to live my life better than what I
have been in the past more war that were
probably not going to be able to fund
any more than what we can without
cutting giving more money into education
and scholarships we continue to have
these negative unequal payments for
minorities and also on equal pay for
women growth for jobs industrial keeping
jobs in America if you can make it
happen inflation goes crazy and the
stock market swings out of control then
we end up in another recession and even
the press petitioner for me would be
from the strength to learn from stars
drunk knows how to make money you know
he's businessman all going to go down to
5 99 for our minimum wage he has no idea
what the normal everyday person have to
do to survive that
we have a healthy balance of bringing
back a lot of our jobs from overseas but
also making sure that we don't
completely isolate ourselves because
there is a world economy keeping it like
it is not having those opportunities to
get a better a better education to grow
you know either vocationally or in a
trade the auto industry would be huge
bringing a whole bunch of jobs here
again that would be tremendous I think
and create these small jobs and small
talent opportunities that he says I
think a lot of people that struggle to
make ends meet well actually have a
little bit of a chance to be lower
middle class middle class
you